avec vous en fera bon jour hélène
bonjour pauline on en parlait à
l'instance de ces après les législatives
difficiles pour emmanuel macron
désormais privé de sa majorité absolue à
l'assemblée le casse-tête du président
condamné désormais à se trouver des
alliés fait la une de toute la presse
française ce matin et notamment des
échos qui annonce vous l'avez dit que
emmanuel macron reçoit aujourd'hui et
demain les responsables des partis
politiques pour tenter de trouver des
majorités au cas par cas texte par texte
le parisien aujourd'hui en france évoque
la recherche de solutions inédites pour
faire voter les réformes et exprime sa
crainte de voir le gouvernement
accaparés par des négociations à n'en
plus finir pour rassembler une majorité
différente pour chaque texte avec le
risque que chaque projet se transforme
je cite un consensus mou encore va-t-il
falloir trouver ses alliés d'autant que
les républicains ne semblent pas
franchement disposée à aider emmanuel
macron le doudou le dessin de quelqu'un
pour l'opinion le patron lr christian
jacob on le voit prévient le président
que nous il ne peut pas s'agrandir de
son côté christian jacob qui ouvrira le
bal ce matin à l'elysée à gauche
maintenant les socialistes on l'a dit
dans le journal les verts et les
communistes refusent la proposition du
patron des insoumis jean luc mélenchon
de former un groupe unique à l'assemblée
d'après le figaro loupé à du patron de
la france insoumise sur l'est du port
est échoué sa proposition de groupe
unique étant présenté comme une façon de
noyer son amertume je cite face au très
bon score du rassemblement national un
président qui est d'allier une extrême
droite plus forte que jamais et une
gauche on entend déjà divisé libération
cite ce commentaire prêté à emmanuel
macron on entre dans le blizzard un
détournement d'une réplique des tontons
flingueurs traduite par un témoin le
président voulait dire que se retrouver
dans une situation de type quatrième
république avec des institutions de la
vème république
cette entrée dans le bizarre bizarre
vous avez dit bizarre le drôle de drame
qui se joue en ce moment à l'assemblée
et si avec attention à l'étranger me
scrutés de très près même par nos
voisins belges du soir qui relativise
les inquiétudes françaises sur une
possible paralysie de la france le
journal belge je soutiens que la
fragmentation politique n'a pas empêché
la belgique de trouver je cite des
solutions souvent ambitieuse grâce à la
conclusion de compromis tout en estimant
qu'un même constat cruel touche à la
fois la france la belgique le fait que
la démocratie serait qu à bout de
souffle là bas comme ici vu de suisse la
nouvelle assemblée nationale ressemble
furieusement paraît-il au parlement
fédéral ou l'art du compromis est une
discipline quotidienne d'après le temps
qu'ils proposent de détailler aux
français en quoi consiste cette
souplesse baisse suisse pardonnez moi
que la classe politique hexagonale va
devoir adopter au plus vite faire des
compromis c'est accepté le risque que la
solution trouvée ne soit pas tout à fait
celle imaginée explique dans les
colonnes du quotidien suisse l'élu
vaudois olivier français ça ne s'invente
pas maintenant on est compromis à la
compromission hélène dans le monde 188
femme demande la démission immédiate du
ministre des solidarités damien abad
accusé par trois femmes de viol ou
tentative de viol est les signataires de
cette tribune qui disent venir de tous
milieux professionnels et de tous bords
politiques jugent que le maintien de
damien abad au gouvernement et je cite
le symptôme de la grande résistance
qu'oppose les réactionnaires aux femmes
qui prennent la parole depuis des années
pour être entendu en reléguant à la
justice le pouvoir unique de trancher le
gouvernement fait preuve d'une grande
lâcheté accuse-t-elle ces femmes disent
demandé à l'exécutif de prendre une
décision politique et non judiciaire ce
n'est pas la justice qui décide de la
nomination des ministres ce n'est donc
pas à elle d'en décider de décider de
leur démission et marine turchi la
journaliste de mediapart à l'origine des
révélations de cette affaire à battre
sera mon invité à 8h15 dans paris direct
direction le mali à présent il est temps
d'en parler avec damien coq et dans le
journal un nouveau massacre a eu lieu ce
week end à diana sa gauche dans le
centre du pays selon un bilan officiel
annoncé hier soir 132 civils auraient
été tués qui pour sauver le mali le
journal burkinabè le pays interpelle
directement le chef de la junte au
pouvoir le colonel assimi goïta en le
prévenant que si la situation
sécuritaire ne s'améliore pas dans les
mois à venir les maliens qui chante
aujourd'hui ses loges le chasserons je
cite comme un malpropre du palais de
koulouba le nouvel homme fort du magny
qui on le sait a fait le choix de mettre
fin à l'opération française barkan et de
recourir aux services de l'analyste
russe wagner également montré du doigt
par le site d'info burkinabè wac est
serra les putschistes qui ont déserté
les camps militaires et ont préféré les
palais ce trait au front sont surtout
occupés à défendre leur pouvoir le
pouvoir qu'ils ont arraché par les armes
je cite on ne se quittent pas la tuer on
évoque souvent ici pauline les méfaits
du tourisme de masse à et les
initiatives diverses et variées à
travers la planète pour tenter d'en
limiter les nuisances dernière idée en
date assez original ma foi
la décision de la ville de vigo c'est en
galice en espagne d'intérieur je cite
l'évacuation physiologiques sur la plage
ou dans la mer sous peine de se voir
infliger une amende de 750 euros le
times précise que les détails sur la
manière exacte d'appliquer cette règle
n'ont pas été communiqués
des gendarmes amphibie ou des hommes
grenouilles peut-être évacuation
physiologique bon appétit merci beaucoup
et l'aisne à tout à l'heure dans paris
direct